♪
>> Bret: AS REFERENCED BREAKING
TONIGHT AN APPARENT AGREEMENT ON
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THE
CORONAVIRUS EMERGENCY.
THE HOUSE SPEAKER MAKING THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT AND RELIEF REACTION
UP ON CAPITOL HILL CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT CHAD PERGRAM LIVE
THERE NOW.
GOOD EVENING, CHAD.
THAT KIND OF EVOLVED WE HEARD
THE PRESIDENT IN THE ROSE GARDEN
SAYING THEY ARE NOT DOING WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
>> THE KEY HERE WAS THE FACT
THAT HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
AND THE SECRETARY OF THE
TREASURY STEVE MNUCHIN SPOKE 12
TIMES TODAY, INCLUDING THREE
TIMES DURING THE PRESIDENT’S
PRESS CONFERENCE IN THE ROSE
GARDEN.
THAT TELLS YOU, DESPITE WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS SAYING, IS THAT
THERE WAS A DEAL TO BE HAD.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
DIDN’T THINK THAT THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES COULD LEAVE WITH
THIS STILL ON THE TABLE.
REMEMBER THE SENATE IS OUT.
THERE WERE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
WHO WERE SQUEAMISH ABOUT
SUPPORTING SOMETHING THAT THE
PRESIDENT WASN’T FULLY BEHIND.
REMEMBER, THEY HAVE HAD PROBLEMS
WITH THE PRESIDENT ON THESE
ISSUES BEFORE.
MITCH MCCONNELL, THE SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER, LEARNED THAT
THE HARD WAY IN 2018 WHEN THEY
HAD AN AGREEMENT, THEY THOUGHT,
ON THE GOVERNMENT FUNDING BILL
AND THEN THERE WAS THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
EVEN KEVIN MCCARTHY THE HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER THOUGHT THERE
WAS AN AGREEMENT EARLIER THIS
WEEK THAT HE NEGOTIATED WITH
BILL BARR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ON FISA.
AND THEN THAT WAS BLOWN UP IN
THE SENATE FOR THE TIME BEING.
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT GETTING
THIS RIGHT.
I SPOKE WITH ONE SENIOR
REPUBLICAN WHO SAID THAT SOME OF
THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES WERE JUST
TECHNICAL.
THIS IS WHY THEY THOUGHT THEY
HAD AN AGREEMENT MAYBE 10:00,
11:00 THIS MORNING AND THEY
MIGHT HAVE THIS BILL ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR.
BUT THIS BILL WILL PROBABLY PASS
LATER TONIGHT WITH AN AMAL GUM
OF DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
WHAT’S KEY HERE, BRET, WE STILL
DON’T HAVE THE BILL TEXT.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AT
ONE POINT THIS AFTERNOON SEEMED
POISE TO GO AHEAD AND PASS HER
OWN BILL WITHOUT ANY REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT AND BASICALLY SAY, LOOK,
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE DONE OUR PART,
THE SENATE IT’S UP TO YOU,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IT’S UP TO YOU.
AND IF YOU DON’T PASS SOMETHING
WE WILL SEE YOU IN NOVEMBER,
BRET.
>> Bret: CHAD, THAT’S IMPORTANT.
PELOSI IN HER LETTER SAID SHE
LISTED A FEW THINGS INCLUDING
SECURED PAID EMERGENCY LEAVE, TO
WEEKS OF PAID SICK LEAVE AND UP
TO THREE MONTHS OF PAID FAMILY
AND MEDICAL LEAVE ENHANCED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
WHAT’S KEY HERE THERE WAS
RUMBLING ABOUT OTHER THINGS
BEING PUT IN THIS BILL,
EXTRANEOUS TO THE CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE.
AND IT MAY PASS THE HOUSE WITH
THE MAJORITY BEING DEMOCRATS,
BUT IT STILL HAS TO GET THROUGH
THE SENATE.
SO EVEN IF THEY MADE A DEAL, IT
STILL HAS ANOTHER HURDLE TO GO
THROUGH.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
THAT’S WHAT MITCH MCCONNELL WAS
WAITING FOR JUST TO SEE WHAT THE
STREET COULD BEAR IN TERMS OF
THE TRAFFIC IN THE TERMS OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THE SENATE, UNLESS THEY DO
SOMETHING BY EXTRAORDINARY
MEASURES AND COME BACK THE
SESSION OVER THE WEEKEND, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO TEE THINGS UP
UNTIL ABOUT 5:30 IN THE SENATE.
THEY ARE GOING TO ADDRESS FISA
THEN.
WHEN YOU TALK TO OTHER SENATE
REPUBLICANS, ROY BLUNT, DEMOCRAT
CHRIS COONS FROM DELAWARE, THEY
THINK THEY CAN PASS A BILL ALONG
THE LINES OF WHAT THE HOUSE WILL
PASS TONIGHT.
AND SEND THAT TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THEY UNDERSTAND HOW GRAVE THIS
SITUATION IS AND THEY CAN’T SIT
THIS ONE OUT.
>> Bret: VERY QUICKLY, I MEAN,
THESE BILLS, SOMETIMES WHEN
THERE IS AN EMERGENCY AND IT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN FAST AND PEOPLE
DON’T SEE WHAT’S IN THE BILL,
THAT GETS TO RAISE SOME
EYEBROWS.
>> ABSOLUTELY, YEAH.
THAT’S WHY PEOPLE WERE
CONCERNED.
THEY WANT TO SEAT DETAILS.
ONE DRAFT OF THIS THAT WE SAW
EARLIER WAS 106 PAGES.
KEEP IN MIND HOW TOUGH IT WAS TO
PASS TARP.
THIS WAS THE -- YOU KNOW, THE
TROUBLED ASSETS RELIEF PROGRAM
IN RESPONSE TO THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS IN 2008.
THAT BILL FAILED IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, DESPITE HOW
GRAVE AND DIRE THE SITUATION
WAS.
HERE THEY ARE GOING TO PASS A
BILL.
YOU KNOW, AND, AGAIN, KEEP IN
MIND, BRET, THIS IS THE EASY
BILL.
THERE IS GOING TO A SECOND AND
THIRD TIER BILL WHICH WILL BE
MUCH MORE COMPLICATED IN THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT HOPING
FOR A PAYROLL TAX CUT SOMEWHERE
IN THERE CHAD PERGRAM, THANK YOU